dent at the dentist attendant today I'm
trying on women's underwear
not just any ladies though Victoria's
Secret underwear I will not like this
this will not be over quickly
you didn't panties actually yeah it into
this pretty okay
these aren't much lower than they appear
let's take a look and you sort of like
spill a little on the sides in the front
there's no way for me to wear these
without something popping out maybe if I
tuck it up this is what girls are always
picking it out of things you see that
see that see that like how high it like
makes my like but seem to go ooh yeah I
like the print like I imagine that the
lower half of my butt just lightly hangs
out of them very sexually hmm a lot of
adjustment needs to be done in this one
these are luxurious it real great the
bottom of my cheeks are hanging out and
what I can only describe as like reverse
muffin top oh yeah make my butt look
good oh yeah that's nice not going it's
not going anywhere very tight I can't
stop rubbing my butt look at that no
jiggle at all I get to keep these right
there's no one else is gonna try them on
oh hell no oh hell no Wow where's the
where's the rest of it oh my this is
going to completely disappear inside of
me ooh it feels like I'm putting on
nothing oh it's right up my butt oh okay
oh this is too small you guys got me one
way too small
coverage on the front minimal to none
because I can see everything you know
like side boob is a thing we're getting
like side net over here
really confusing like if this is my
underwear my balls are like SH mark
feels like somebody put some string in
my bike
my ass is literally sucking them up like
a vacuum no my butt ate the fabric if it
came it saw it conquered it just snarfed
it right up I wish you guys could have
seen what they look like clearly these
were not made to accommodate my shapes
it was so comfortable well it kind of
hurt men oh you want your guy to look
sexy don't put them in your underwear
ladies always say walk a mile on their
shoes
I'll do you one better I'll walk a mile
on stong we'll have some severe chafing
from that but I'll do it just to learn
to Scrabble